tv
48 hours of programs about non-fiction
books authors and the publishing
industry
every weekend here on c-span 2.
this best-seller by howard zinn offers a
historical look at the us through the
stories of people not usually covered in
traditional histories
next mr zinn discusses his approach and
his views on how lessons from the past
make a difference to the future
he spoke at the san francisco bay area
book festival and he's introduced by
board director cheryl fullerton
okay it is my great pleasure to
introduce howard zinn a respected
professor historian and author of the
landmark a people's history of the
united states 1492 to the present he's
taught at boston university and spelman
college would you all please join me in
welcoming howard zinn
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
uh
i'm putting my watch down
to pretend that i care
um but
i don't know how much you know about my
book or what's in the book maybe you
know everything that i have to say to
you
uh
but
uh i will talk about my book
uh because i don't know what else to
talk about i'll tell you how i came to
write it and
why i came to write it in this funny way
and uh
i wrote the book in the sort of late
1970s
i guess when i had some breathing space
after
the anti-war movement
you know you know during the anti-war
movement we were all doing all these
furious things you know it was you know
the senate many of you know this the war
was the center of our lives and we were
running around the country and doing
this and that and
and there was no time
uh
certainly no time to write a 700 page
book so i was putting out little things
you know 125 page book
uh called vietnam the logical withdrawal
and 100 page book called disobedience
and democracy
you know
no more time
so but now i had time so i decided to
write what people had been
uh looking for or at least people would
approach me
and say you know you've
been teaching american history and so on
can you recommend a good one-volume
history of the united states from
a radical point of view
no
[Laughter]
well not really
i don't want to go into bibliographical
detail about what there is and what
there isn't but not exactly you know
but these were the demands that came out
of the movements of the 60s because out
of the movements of the 60s people were
looking for something different people
were remembering the kind of history
they had learned in high school and
college and with thinking this doesn't
fit what i see in the world today
and so they were looking for something
and just so i decided to write something
to
to fill that need
uh now
clearly those of you know the book came
uh
i know that i came to that history from
a very definite point of view
uh
and i guess this is because when i began
to study history when i began to when i
decided i would that's what i would do i
would write history and i would teach
history
i already knew
that i was not going to be a neutral
teacher i was not going to be a neutral
historian
uh i have a memoir called notice how i'm
advertising all my books
isn't this a book festival you know yeah
i have many more you'll hear many more
things like that
uh and i'll just try not to mention
other people's books
but
the uh
but
i i wrote a memoir called you can't be
neutral on a moving train
and then the the idea of is it came from
things i would say to my classes at the
beginning of the class i would say now
look you know
this is not going to be a neutral class
this is not going to be one of those
classes and where you spend a semester
or a year with a teacher at the end of
the semester at the end of the year you
have no idea where this teacher stands
on the important issues of the day we've
all had teachers like that
right
there a lot of them
no i i wasn't going to be neutral i had
a point of view at a strong point of
view
and i wasn't going to hold back on it
because i didn't believe that
well
you might say i had a very modest desire
in going into history i just wanted to
change the world
and and i figured you can't change the
world if you're neutral and besides to
be neutral no
well
the world is already moving in certain
directions there's no such there's no
real thing neutrality it
doesn't exist
the world is already moving in certain
directions wars are going on children
are going hungry
terrible things are being done to be
neutral in such a world is to
collaborate with what is going on
and so no i wasn't going to be neutral
as a historian
and uh and yes
i kind of knew as i started to write
this book what my point of view
uh was going to be and it came out of my
background it came out of my life
experience it came out of the fact that
at the age of 18 i
didn't go to college i went to work in a
shipyard
i stayed in the shipyard for three years
i didn't do it as a sociological
experiment
you know
ah let's go interview the shipyard
workers
and
do an oral history of shipyard workers
yeah no that wasn't it you know it just
came from that kind of background that
kind of family that kind of neighborhood
and working class parents and so on
struggling no no thought of going to
college when you got 18 everybody around
me went to work at the age of 18. so i
worked in
a shipyard for three years and helped
organize the young shipyard workers who
were excluded from the afl unions black
people were excluded from the unions
women were excluded from the unions
unskilled workers were sick and so we
formed the uh a kind of industrial union
an iww almost that's what we like to
think you know whenever we do something
good we like to compare ourselves to the
iww let's see and we were uh
so you might say i grew up class
conscious
uh with a phrase you don't hear much in
the united states you know that is we're
not supposed to we're not supposed to
have classes in the united states
we're all one big happy family
you see
all of our interests are the same
you know uh exxon and me
you know
you know the
uh
and you know
the founding fathers and all of us you
know
the uh i mean the very you know name
founding fathers we're related by blood
to those slave owners
who sat in on the making of the
constitution
yeah uh no we're we're
no we're not one big family despite the
the attempts on the part of the
establishment to draw us all in to this
net and say our interests are one you
hear them talking about ah this is this
in our national interest
is this in the interest of national
security actually it may be in the
interest of somebody's securities
but not in the interest of
national security you see but all these
world these phrases are supposed to
envelop us all in one common bond of
interest instead and thus hiding the
fact that we are a society of many
different interests
of uh
people who are rich and people who are
poor and a lot of people in between who
are nervous
and uh so we uh you know black and white
and men and women and immigrants no it's
uh it's uh it's a society of of people
in and stressful relationship with one
another and so
i wanted to write a history which would
beef
from a class conscious point of view
i wasn't
going to write about the founding
fathers and making the constitution and
you know and glorify the constitution
which was written by 55 rich white men
in philadelphia i wasn't going to do
that even though you know i was taken
aback for a moment when you know ronald
reagan during the bicentennial year of
the
constitution in 1987 ronald reagan wrote
an essay
could you believe that
ronald reagan wrote an essay for us you
know some scholarly magazine uh parade
magazine
[Applause]
in which he talked about the
constitution
and said you know the
the constitution
uh
only have been created
with the guiding hand of god
you know
well
i thought
this was really an insult to god
when you consider you know the
constitution was written to to
perpetuate the wealth to perpetuate
slavery uh to perpetuate things as they
were to replace the british ruling class
with a local ruling class that's what
the constitution was written for i'm
sorry to be so harsh on the founding
fathers they're nice guys they look good
they dress well
you know they're very eloquent
uh
but no i was gonna write about history
from from i
i didn't want to write about american
industrial progress as it was presented
to me in high school it was presented to
me in high school i remember sitting
there in class and this is the period of
the great american industrial revolution
when america became a great economic
power you know that period between a
civil war and world war one when when
you know and i remember sitting there
transfixed as the figures were put up on
the board of how many more steel ingots
were being produced each year you know
how many
miles of railroad track and the
transcontinental railroad wow how
romantic and how beautiful and we were
so proud
nothing was said
in those classes and nothing was said in
my textbooks about who worked on those
railroads about the irish immigrants and
the chinese immigrants who worked on
those railroads and died in great
numbers in the sickness and the heat in
those railroads i was going to wasn't
going to tell about the great industrial
miracle of the united states that
leaving out the girls who went to work
in the textile mills of new england at
the age of 12 and died at the age of 25.
now
and i wasn't going to look at the the
state of the country from the standpoint
of the dow jones average
no i mean this if you look historically
you know and i was sort of prepared for
this by
by some of my work in
in history i was prepared looking back
at eras which had been triumphantly
proclaimed as wonderful errors you know
remember the era of goodwill
they still have that in the textbooks
but they certainly have
you know
the roaring 20s
the jazz age the age of prosperity i
mean history is very simple the 20s were
prosperous everybody was prosperous in
the 20s
and everybody was depressed in the 30s
so
uh
but i did i was doing a study of
fiorello laguardia my my first
book i mentioned another book yes
never miss an opportunity uh first
my
my doctoral distinction actually was on
lola guardia and
a lot of you know who fiorello laguardia
is some people
yes i mean some people you know think
you know he's an airport you know
but he was you know a lot of people know
he was mayor of new york very colorful
character but before that a lot of
people don't know this and i didn't know
this until i started working he was a
congressman
in the 1920s representing east harlem
representing a poor district east harlem
an interesting congressman the most
radical member of congress
he was a republican
and a socialist
[Music]
don't ask don't ask me
don't ask me to explain that you see
but
but i i was reading the letters
that laguardia's constituents were
writing to him from east harlem in the
1920s in the age of prosperity
the jazz age and these letters from his
constituents were saying
help me
yeah my husband is out of work my kids
don't have enough to eat they've turned
off the gas
you know
and uh
i know it's true all over the country
but nobody noticed it because the
headlines were about the wall street and
the stock market and how well it was
doing
and and you i mean
you learn about today when you read
about history if you don't learn about
today if you learn don't learn about
today when you're learning about history
then there's no not much point you know
except fun oh yeah he's not fun but i
never wanted to be a historian who went
into the past and got lost
you know there are you know you're going
it's the past is interesting
you go in and you read those letters and
the documents and it's detective work
and it's fun
you know but you can get lost there i
never i didn't want to do that i wanted
to see what i could find and come out
and apply it to what was going on in the
world
i left the shipyard to enlist in the air
force
and
you can tell i'm a kind of military
person
and
but it was
it was there was a war on
uh
no not the spanish-american war
no it's world war ii the war against
fascism and i was imbued there's a lot
of young uh yeah young radicals were
imbued young everybody you know yes the
war against fascism let's you know and
so i i i became a bombardier in the air
force and flew bombing drop bombs and
where drop bombs are dropped meaning not
where they're intended to go
uh
sometimes where they are intended to go
which sometimes is worse
but in any case
i became a bombardier and and but i came
out of this this is the good war as you
know
right this is the the best of wars
uh
i wrote a book
i wrote a book once called post-war
america and i had a chapter in it about
world war ii and chapter was called the
best of wars
and studs turkle
you know wrote the good war
uh later and uh and but it's a wonderful
book
if you notice if you look at the book
closely the phrase the good war in studs
turkle's book is surrounded by quotation
marks
yeah because it's not that simple it's
not that clear it's not that unambiguous
it's very complicated and i came out of
that good war in which i had been an
eager bombardier came out of the war
convinced that war solves nothing
the war doesn't solve
fundamental human problems and even when
it seems to do so even when it starts
off looking that way even when the enemy
is vicious and you because the enemy is
vicious you look good this is a common
mistake the mistake is that if the enemy
is evil you must be good
well
uh
it was uh i came out of the war
uh persuaded that uh war
yeah
well it didn't take long there were
those promises made in in world war ii
those promises you know this would be
we're going to defeat fascism and we're
going to have a wonderful new world
right we can have a world you know we're
not going to have racism anymore because
we're going to defeat hitler it
represents racism we're not going to
have war anymore we're not going to have
militarism anymore no we're going to
have the u.n we're going to
have yeah
well it doesn't take much
observation of the years that follow
world war ii uh to begin to ask the
question if 50 million people died in
world war ii what did they die for
for this kind of world with a
perpetuation of war and militarism and
racism and yes in fascism and nooks and
crannies all over the world including
our own country
fascism is not confined to national
boundaries
fascism exists in every prison in this
country
really
you know and uh there
exists in the military
they're you know
yeah
so
anyway the point is
that from this point on
uh
if i was going to deal in history with
war
and writing history and teaching history
i had a very strong point of view and
the point of view was anti-war
and my personal experience
uh
like
dropping napalm on
a little village in france
toward the end of the war
and killing
german frenchmen whoever happened to be
there
basically to test out napalm that's the
only reason i could figure out for doing
it was the first use of napalm you know
it's uh and then watching the bombing of
hiroshima and nagasaki and all and then
reading john hersey and and having the
stories of the people
you know children caught in in that uh
no i was i wasn't going to be neutral on
the question of war and i was going to
look at war from the standpoint of the
statesmen and the decision makers the
generals i was going to look at war from
the standpoint of the gis and the
soldiers and the the the young men uh
cajoled and coerced into going to war
i also wanted to look at war from the
standpoint of the other side
yeah and this is something you don't
think about let's look at war from the
standpoint of the enemy
the other people right let's look at a
mexican war from the standpoint of the
mexicans
well when you look at the mexican war
from the standpoint of the mexians
well here we are
we're in mexican territory
i'm right we this is this was part of
mexico and we stole it
i mean there's no other word for it
uh
we uh we
provoked a war with mexico so that we
could take half of mexico
some people thought we were being
moderate we should have taken all of
mexico
but no we took
no i wanted to tell a story of mexico of
that war yeah from the standpoint of the
gis who woke up one day
american
immigrant kids who just out of for the
same reason that most young people
joining wars join out of desperation and
need and desire to to get ahead or
whatever you know and then find
themselves in a bloody mess which they
want any part of and so they began
deserting from the american army in the
mexican war
uh yeah from their point of view from
the point of view of the of the mexicans
and so you know and so it was my
experience and it was history also when
i looked at the history of wars and
history of america's wars you know i
know there are good wars and bad wars
good wars in bed we have these lists
right good wars and bad wars
i had a student once who wrote
you know they treat wars like wines
this is a good year this is a bad year
he said
but war is not like wine
war is like cyanide one drop in your
um
and uh
and all the experience
of you know in all the other wars
uh
since
the war to end all wars
since world war ii
uh
sort of
confirmed you know what i felt about war
and you know and of course right up to
this very day
and i wanted to one of the things i
wanted to get across
to
students is to lose their subservience
to power lose their subservience to
authority lose their subservience to
so-called experts
and there was no
more vivid lesson during the vietnam war
then
lesson about experts and i remember
people at the beginning of the anti-war
movement saying well wait a while
you know
these people in washington i mean why do
you think they're there they know what
they're doing
really
really
i mean just look at the history of what
people in washington have done and asked
they know what they're doing
i mean they they they're gonna be phi
beta kappa and they were in the kennedy
and johnson administration they were the
the best and the brightest they were the
smart right and
and and they engaged in the most stupid
and most immoral set of actions that
we've had in the history of our country
for a long time so i wanted my students
to to learn to think for themselves and
to to to
learn and seek out information for
themselves not to depend you know on
what the president says what the media
say oh what the textbook said not even
what my book said but to look things up
for themselves and make them make up
their own minds
so
and then after i
i'm continuing my little
autobiographical romp you see year by
year will only take a few hours
and
the
so i
i went to college under the gi bill
i love it when
people say the era you know we mustn't
have big government
we mustn't government do things for
people
right
government is doing too much
for
mothers taking care of kids who are
collecting 350 a month
really you know the government's not
good it creates dependency
oh really
when we give billions of dollars to the
corporations does that create dependency
no uh no
uh big government
and uh
it was different during the new deal
when people began to realize government
all the government has mostly been on
the side of the rich and powerful it is
possible sometimes for government to do
something for the poor as it did in the
1930s when it passed social security of
course under the impetus of social
movements under the impetus of the labor
movement and so on and the evidence of
strikes all over the country and tenant
strikes and so on but good things were
done by government in that time
and people have forgotten about that and
some people deliberately want to forget
about that and say big government is no
good uh but the gi bill
was big government it was the government
giving
four years of free education to
everybody who served in world war ii and
so i went through my entire educational
thing right up through the phd never
paid a dollar in tuition
i know the young people looking at me
rather enviously at this point
yeah so i studied history at nyu
columbia my first teaching job spelman
college atlanta georgia black women's
college
and uh
did marion arrive yet
no she may never no she'll arrive
yes she'll arrive
but
seven years at spelman college
my wife and kids
got into our old chevy and went down to
atlanta and spent the next seven years
1956 to 63 uh
very special time to be in the south and
to be living in the black community and
to see the first the the you know the
tremors under the surface
uh
begin to develop and then see things
burst out in 1960 you know with the
sit-ins in 61 with the freedom rides and
62 and 63 in albany georgia and
birmingham and the mass demonstrations
and
thousands and tens of thousands and
hundreds of thousands of people being
involved an amazing amazing episode in
our history out of which i learned an
enormous amount
uh i certainly learned more from my
years at spelman and my students learned
from me
i learned a lot about politics i learned
about education i learned a lot about
democracy
i learned about well one thing i learned
about education you know the business of
you know see history from a different
point of view when you look at history
from a black point of view it looks
different
you know look history from a women's
point of view it looks different
from uh
yeah
and uh
from a native american point of view
uh
from the native american point of view
take the revolutionary war as we know
that was a good war
right on how can you beat the
revolutionary war
i you know it's it's it's you know
there are the statues all over there i
mean here i come from boston i mean
boston would die if not for the
revolutionary war and the statues that
it can have in its public square
but boston needs their you know all of
that uh but
uh
and the revolutionary war yes it it
freed us from england
from the point of view of the indians it
was a disaster
the british had set a line beyond which
the colonists could move west into
indian territory proclamation of 1763 we
win the war against england we abolish
the line and then we move into indian
territory and all across the country and
then follows a hundred years of
massacres
right
uh another
so very neglected set of episodes in
american history
uh
all i learned about was sitting bull at
custer's last stand
but
from history from black point of view
looks looks certainly different the
heroes look different
uh the uh all the traditional heroes
look different the eras and their names
look different you know everybody learns
about the progressive everybody who
takes american history learns about the
progressive era in american history
right i think they still they must still
have that in the books always look
progressive here the first 20 years of
the 20th century when it's called a
progressive area because various reforms
were passed you know
railroad regulation
and uh the meat inspection act
notice how good our meat is as a result
of that
and uh the
uh the you know federal reserve system
the federal trade commission the direct
election of senators etc
graduated income tax i notice how
graduated our income taxes these days
yeah well anyway but reform so it's the
progressive era those were exactly the
years those that in that progressive era
when more black people were lynched in
this country than in any other period of
american history
so you know i began to read the black
historians who are not on my reading
lists in colombia
really they were not
uh and then of course i learned you know
well just by becoming involved in the
movement just becoming involved in that
movement that you know that my students
uh
initiated
they always think that faculty you know
whenever students are involved you
notice that doing a video on what i
think faculty must have some faculty
person must have instigated it's never
that way the students start it the
faculty people come in
you know some
but you learn about uh
learned a lot about education learned
that education is not simply what you
get in a classroom it's what you learn
out in the midst of a social struggle
i remember
when my students when marion and a whole
bunch of other
students of spelman and morehouse etc
were getting arrested in downtown
atlanta for sitting in
one of my colleagues
a political scientist
a phd from johns hopkins
i want to give him his full due before i
wrote a letter to the atlantic
constitution
deploring that his students who are
missing class
and going downtown to participate in
these demonstrations their education
they're losing out on their education
well obviously this man was losing out
on his education he didn't understand
what education was and didn't understand
that people learn more in the heat of
social struggle
than they can simply by books and
classrooms sure books and classrooms are
good and you come back from the picket
line and come back to the classroom and
you want to read more and learn more i
want to read more history of what it is
you were involved with
so yeah i learned a lot i learned i
learned from my students
i learned well
i learned
never to mistake silence for
um
agreement
you know now because you know
you look you looked at the surface looks
came to spelman college in 1956 things
that look quiet
everybody's well behaved people are
going you know they're doing their
lessons they're going to do the right
things to become successful do what
their parents want them to do and become
you know
people of some substance and use in the
black segregated community right
[Music]
well
that's the way it looked
uh and you could looking at that surface
of quiet and silent you would see as
some people so many people say about the
students today or about people today
where are they they're not doing
anything you know
never look at the surface of things this
is what i learned
i always assume that if something is
wrong there's a under the surface
there's a kind of uh
common sense understanding that
something is wrong i believe in this
country there's a common on sense
understanding that there's something
wrong with spending 270 billion dollars
on weaponry when
40 million people are without health
insurance and and health you know other
people you know there's kind of people
understand that you know
and people
fundamentally understand things you know
and uh but very often they're quiet
about it they're practical uh they're
waiting for the right moment they're
waiting for somebody to make the first
move uh and
uh
and so you know at a certain point my my
students at spelman burst out you know
of that silence and they and young
people and older people all over the
south uh black people uh all over the
south uh
just uh
galvanized the country and the world and
embarrassed the us government into
finally doing something
one of the things we learned at that
time you don't depend on the government
don't depend on even the most liberal
government i mean we had had liberal
governments and conservative governments
we had democrats and republicans for 100
years in this country after the passage
of the 14th amendment 14th men were
supposed to guarantee racial equality
and and it didn't matter who was in
power in washington they didn't do a
thing to enforce the 14th amendment
until black people in the 1950s and
1960s came out on mass and embarrassed
the government of the united states into
doing something
that was when democracy came alive
democracy is not a set of of procedures
it's not a
framework
uh democracy is people giving you
something to drink when you're thirsty
you know
and
so yeah democracy came alive in the 60s
you know democracy as i said is not
you know it's not what we learned in
junior high school ah
this is democracy i'm going to put it on
the blackboard here are the three
branches of government executive
legislative judicial is the constitution
that's democracy
vote every two year four years that's
the no
no if we depended on that
we would be
lost
more than we are
the thing that
changed things
to the extent that they did change for
black people for working people in this
country for women for disabled people
for people who against what i think
the government of the united states did
not initiate any of the things that were
necessary to remedy those grievances
people had to go out and create
movements
uh in order to bring that about and then
if the movement became strong enough and
loud enough
and persistent enough then the
government responded
that was the lesson of democracy
so
what else should i say
what what other books of mine haven't i
mentioned
well
maybe
maybe
it's possible but
how about questions
how about questions
yes i'm finished
[Applause]
thank you
yeah
there's a microphone set up back here
there's a microphone set up right back
there in case people
can't project oh
uh is it bad if people speak from their
seats
yeah
does uh
c-span not like that
i mean who do you think we're doing this
for
how
mike
what you want people to line up behind
the mic yeah well
is it can people speak from their seats
is that all right
and then i repeat the question and
distort it as i usually do okay
yes
yes go ahead
i'm curious about
gallaudet university
in 1988
the big revolt was called deaf president
now
and deaf people really mobilized
and then
they closed the university at that time
called the college they posted for a
week to do the deaf president now
revolt so i'm wondering
that had a large impact on american
history at least deaf people think so
but
i was looking
and
the section about
history during that period of time and
there was no mention at all of deaf
president now
yeah so it hasn't really impacted
american history according to the books
my my book or books generally
well general history generally general
history including my book
yeah really i'm i'm ashamed to say this
but from time to time people have
pointed out the things i've missed in my
book you know i've missed a lot
yeah and uh
and
you know when the first edition of the
book came out i i really
didn't do justice to the struggles
of chicano people in this country
uh didn't do justices struggles of gay
and lesbian people in this country
didn't do justice to the struggles of
disabled people or you know to this
event which was a i remember that event
and to me it was such a perfect example
of democracy coming alive where you know
students protest in this remarkable way
to have a president who represents their
own situation yeah and that was a
wonderful event and i'm going to make
note of it
for the
next time there's another printing of my
book
and the printings come fast
so
i i will make a really i'll make a note
of that
i wish you'd send me some stuff
okay you do email
do you do email
but i don't know your email address i'll
tell you my email address
it's god everybody's listening
don't listen
[Music]
h z
h is in
at
b u
dot e d u
got it
h is in
at
b u
be it like a boy
dot e-d-u
yes
many of us
thought that the world war ii
was just another imperialist war
being fought between two towers
trying to capture territory
but then after world war ii
seeing what hitler had done
seeing what the role of hitler had been
some of us changed began to think about
that war as maybe it was had been
necessary
to fight in it what i just wondered what
your whether you had changed in your
estimation
that do you want me to repeat do i have
to repeat that oh yeah asking me the
most difficult question
that
i get that question
a lot
and it is
if i could if i could know in advance
that a person would ask that question i
wouldn't recognize them
because this
uh
but there there it is it's out
she's asking me at world war ii and
saying that she started off with a
notion it's an imperialist war you know
imperialist on both sides but then when
with the stories of the death camps you
know when the holocaust and all of that
she changed her mind about the war
well that's the reason i say it's a
tough question because it's very very
complex
you know
and
you know
let me say this something had to be done
about fascism right something had to be
done about hitler the only question is
what it had to be done in the way that
it was done
and whether it didn't come late
you see late because the main concern of
the people of the nations fighting the
war was not the jews and not racism and
not militarism it wasn't their concern
you see and but it's true that even you
know that there are unintended
consequences of
bad
intentions right and so
um
the thing the thing i would come away
from
i'd say world war ii is complex we did
not have to kill huge numbers of
civilians in german cities and we didn't
have to drop the bombs on hiroshima and
nagasaki and i didn't have to drop
napalm on this little town in france so
something had to be done about fascism
and the question that's left is was
there any way
to
fight against fascism
without at some point in the war
beginning to duplicate the atrocities of
the other side
you see i mean that's a big question and
it's a very unanswerable question
because it's all gone
the only i'll just say one more thing
the problem with world war ii having
such elements of goodness and
questioning about it the problem with it
is
that is the ambiguity of world war ii
uh
the problem with that
is that to the extent that world war ii
can be seen as a good war it cast a soft
glow on every war that has followed
since wars which don't have that
ambiguity wars which are crass
imperial wars but world war ii is is
used it's used as a metaphor and it's
used to justify korea vietnam the gulf
war kosov it's they pull it out every
time you see to to help them justify
unjustifiable
killing
so
world war ii was passed
the real question is how do we react to
the wars today and how do we react to to
the wasting our enormous national
treasures on preparation for war
yes
i wanted to ask about your involvement
with the end the sanctions against iraq
campaign my involvement with what the
end the sanctions against iraq campaign
involvement with the sanctions against
the iraq campaign
you all know about the sanctions against
iraq you all know that we've been
carrying on ever since the gulf war
it's interesting how many americans
don't know about if you took a poll in
the united states and asked of how
you would find most americans do not
know that we've been carrying on a
campaign of sanctions which have killed
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
children children in iraq
which leads me to a parenthetical remark
no i'll hold that
let me know when marion arrives
somebody you know like we have a spotter
uh and uh
but
uh
i mean i haven't been involved in it
except talking about it you know and
telling about having been one of those
heroic people who in the voices of the
wilderness who have those people who are
breaking the law the american law and
and bringing food and medicine to iraq
and they've done it you know 15 16 times
and one of the most shameful episodes in
recent american history carried on by
you know the liberal clinton
administration really and justified by
it in the most awful ways
and uh
the uh
and
i mean sort of
there's an enormous disproportion of
attention
to atrocities depending on what the
people in power want us to pay attention
to
and i mean all atrocities should be paid
attention to but the fact is if
thousands of people are killed in kosovo
that is brought to our attention and it
should be brought to our attention
although the thousands of people we then
kill in bombing in order presumably to
do something about that's not brought to
our attention and the hundreds of
thousands of people who die as a result
of our sanctions that's not brought to
our attention we have a real problem in
getting past
what the media tells us is important
and deciding for ourselves on the basis
of searching out independent sources of
information deciding for ourselves what
really is important
i don't know what else i can say about
it i don't i have a feeling that
you know sometimes behind questions you
know there's an answer right that is the
people who ask the questions they know
the answer they want
right and that i feel is an answer you
wanted which you didn't get
am i right no i actually i just i saw
your name in the newspaper with with
many other scholars and i just wondered
how you got involved with the issue well
you wonder how i got involved
that's easy
getting involved is easy
you know people get to know after a
while
who would get involved in such a thing
you see
and you know and if you know and if you
know
you know if i can
you know be on you know
the list of american airlines who but i
can certainly be on the stop sanctions
against iraq list
yes
well there's a man way back there who's
held his hand up for a long time
why is it so extraordinarily difficult
for either the government and or
private enterprise to provide
at least
sufficient shelters for the homeless
particularly in our urban centers
because i recall
some time ago a man
who wanted to open up i think a deserted
post office warehouse
right next to the white house and he had
to fast and he finally got on tv and
somehow the federal government opened up
that warehouse for temporary shelter i
mean again
along with your point about 444 million
people not insured in our country with
health insurance
it's very shameful that we cannot
provide at least shelter for the
homeless is it not i mean one that's
obvious is it not shame is it not
shameful
yes
uh that's an easy one right is it
because of the politics
homeless people don't vote right yeah
and a lot of uh you know and therefore
it uh
it uh and very often you know people who
are the most most agreed most harassed
have the least resources to fight back
and therefore they depend on the rest of
us to speak up for them like prisoners
in jail who are not in a position to
fight back you know and who
in you know and and they need people on
the outside to advocate for them and the
same thing is true of the homeless it's
you know instead of asking how sure we
should ask why isn't the government
doing this and we should ask you know
why aren't the people who have homes
speaking up in loud voices for the
homeless you know
uh who's had a hand up for a long time
all right go ahead
yes
about
individual acts of violence as part of
revolution
and what you think is there a separation
is there a time at which individual acts
of violence are
um
effective and uh a good idea as opposed
to war
she asks uh
maybe you've got did you all get that no
let's ask about i i'm obviously
speaking against the violence of war and
she asked me what about the violence of
individuals
i i assume you mean the violence of
individuals presumably for some good
purpose
right
[Music]
and
well
it always looks
violence is very tempting
because it
very often seems to offer a quick
solution
for a problem
that you face
but it's poisonous
it's
it has consequences
uh which simply spread
uh the idea of violence it's and which
reinforce
uh the acts of violence that are carried
on on a large scale in fact the two
things reverberate
the government's acts of violence i
believe uh encourage those individual
acts of violence which then are deplored
oh how horrible if they you know they
they've you know blow up the right the
building in oklahoma city or they you
know they do this and and that's looked
upon with horror by the same of people
who were ready to kill thousands of
people and have you know in bombing
campaigns there's a connection between
the two there's a connection between
violence and schools and violence in the
streets and violence that comes out of
washington
and we ought to you know think about
that kind of hypocrisy uh but i don't i
don't believe that violence
uh is a solution
uh i think uh the the
poet june jordan who lives i think
somewhere
in the bay area talks when she talked
about the gulf war you know she said
war is like crack
it's a quick fix and then you know when
it it's over you know you realize what
what terrible harm
has been done
i think the great the great problem for
human ingenuity in this
next hundred years now that we're you
know at this
date and encounter we like to talk about
the next hundred years very wisely
and but i think that you know the
problem yeah is how do we solve the
fundamental problems of hunger and
disease you know uh
and
uh injustice and how do we do it without
killing large numbers of people
that is how do we do it while renouncing
war you know as a solution you know
that's the
i mean that's what i mean that's what
human ingenuity is
should be used for
[Applause]
i didn't want her to miss my talk
okay i'm starting over
i'm gonna do the whole thing over again
oh yeah great to see you
thank you
very much thanks for the night
um
i don't think she deserves a moment of
rest
because i came to hear you oh yeah you
came to hear me how are you doing
i'm so good
okay
oh well
there should be a way howard zinn is a
historian playwright and social activist
this book a people's history of the
united states is published by harper
collins a 20th anniversary edition was
released last month
48 hours of non-fiction